allez on va maintenant parler un drôle
de spectacle un spectacle multi
artistique avec vous en train de bonbons
soir vice président de l'association
faut que ça bouge et alors jeu de mots
merveilleux ça va bouger à la salle
jacques-brel jeudi soir avec le
spectacle inspiré sens de quoi s'agit-il
alors on connaît bien faut que ça bouge
à travers la jonglerie ou bien les
percussions et puis cette année on a
ouvert une nouvelle section c'est une
section de technique vocale et de chants
et scénique pardon et avec une
professeure de talent multi artistique
dominique sylvain de là est venue l'idée
de produire un spectacle de créer un
spectacle avant l'été producteur de
spectacles avec la convention passe la
jongle à tes voisins et cette année on a
voulu produire un spectacle une création
multi artistique alors inspiré sens
c'est à la fois inspiration et
essence donc le principe l'histoire
c'est deux artistes qui sont en quête
d'inspiration et qu'ils vont faire un
voyage introspectif pour retrouver la
bonne inspiration donc faire un voyage
d'émotion et ses émotions sont
retranscrits à travers divers arts je
reviens comme sur le concept parce que
c'est c'est vraiment pas comment des
mélanges et à la fois du champ il y aura
de la magie la jonglerie de la
percussion c'est vraiment pas qu'au
courant est-ce que vous n'êtes pas peur
de désarçonner un peu public ou au
contraire vous dit on va créer de la
diversité quoi alors voilà on est on
apprécie les comédies musicales las un
mix entre comédie musicale est un
collectif d'artistes qui propose des
arts très variés
alors il ya une dynamique et une
construction et une histoire dont il ya
un lien à travers tout césar et nous
faut que ça bouge on aime bien la
diversité des arts donc effectivement de
la magie avec le champion de france de
magie qui nous fait l'honneur de venir
de la danse on a associé est licite dans
ce qu'on connaît bien pour le faire a
toujours un choix aussi sympathique en
danse le chant puisque c'est la nouvelle
section qui souffre et qui va faire le
lion avec tous les arts la jonglerie
puisque bas c'est un peu aussi et la
percussion c'est les origines un petit
peu de faut que ça bouge la jonglerie
c'est la recherche de plein d'art
différence toujours la création et c'est
ce qu'on recherche dans faut que ça
bouge c'est une création et cette
création artistique s'est inspiré sens
combien d'artistes sur scène ou là alors
chan il ya une dizaine de chanteuse en
jongleurs on est 4 4 ou 5 magicien de
danseurs 20 donc il ya un gros collectif
tout ça c'est assez gêné joyeusement
exactement ces deux heures non-stop
c'est faut que ça bouge alors il y aura
un entracte quand même puisque c'est
très tellement intense qu'il faut
essayer reposer l'esprit et puis bah
pour nous ça a été l'occasion aussi pour
les jongleurs de créer un spectacle des
numéros spécifique pour l'occasion et
giresse ces deux heures de bons moments
en ce moment il ya les soldes on va être
fatigué il fait mouche en ce moment
alors je vous invite jeudi 27 à 20h30 et
en plus c'est pas cher c'est 5 euros
oui je vais dire ça c'est 5 euros pour
les adultes et 3 euros pour les enfants
effectivement c'est pas très cher alors
aller voir un spectacle qui mêle autant
de choses là et ils et les percussions
c'est le coeur de l'association oui
c'est l'origine on est parti c'est parti
d'une personne qui est parti en afrique
et qui voulait promouvoir les
percussions des percussions on est
arrivé aux arts de la rue puisque la
percussion la jonglerie c'est le rythme
et puis le rythme c'est aussi le chant
est donc tout ça en fait se retrouve la
magie c'est l'esprit féerique de faut
que ça bouge aussi des arts de la rue
donc c'est des arts qu'on a choisi
qu'ils ont à celje et la danse parce que
faut que ça bouge chez aussi bouger on a
été alors de donner des cours de danse
africaine avant il y aura d'ailleurs un
petit moment de danse africaine
donc c'est une vraie balade artistique
puisque c'est toute cette introspection
va passer par diverses émotions du joies
de la joie aux larmes un peu la féerie
c'est l'esprit d'inspirer sens c'est une
première en vous attend nombreux pour
l'instant on peut toujours réserver
venus réserver ou venir le jour j c'est
demain il reste des places c est une
belle salle et
voilà c'est on a eu cette occasion de
pouvoir bénéficier de cette salle et
donc on a voulu les produire un
spectacle j'espère de qualité et pour
petits et grands puisque tout le monde
peut vraiment suivre et chacun soit
comprendront des nuances de phrases ou
bien ne serait ce que par le visuel on
va apprécier justement le visuel vous en
parler c'est important on va voir un
petit extrait qui concerne seulement les
percussions parce que c'est vraiment
l'essence même de l'association sont les
percussions aulas et des percussions je
ne regarde pas comme les autres non je
ne dis rien je ne dis rien ses créateurs
à découvrir on regarde un extrait du
spectacle inspiré sens
oh
oui antoine les gens vous applaudissent
mais c'est ultra mérité moi je suis
bluffé on vous voit en avion au bout de
la table quand on vous arrivez chacun à
faire ils pointent en cadence est
absolument magnifique ce ballet de
baraki bouge dans tous les sens alors
c'est le travail la répétition voilà
comme tout à ça demande beaucoup
d'engagement et de temps et d'essayer
d'être le plus juste possible la
rythmique veut que faut être précis et à
d'associer en même temps c est petit et
ce visuel on s'est inspiré de deux
choses qui existent et on a essayé de
recréer par là dessus de nouvelles
créations après des choses avec bébé
enfin je n'en dévoile pas trop parce
qu'ils t'en veux juste sans toucher le
micro oui en tout cas c'est tout leur
est là pour nous faire une petite démo
alors est ce que
je dirai en régie donc ça a dû le son a
dû et je sais pas voilà je préfère pas
ça a été on m'a dit que ça a été la
vedette a fait sauter tous le sont allés
un mot maintenant sur un animaux sur
l'association foksabouge association a
été créée il ya douze ans oui au moins
oui peut-être plus maintenant raté nous
ce que vous proposez comme cours alors
et les nouveaux courts que vous avez
proposé qu'on vient de très bien
fonctionner les nouveautés à la rue
balore faut que donc il ya des cours de
percussions africaines des cours de
jonglerie on essaie de monter des
spectacles des cours de technique vocale
et de chants et scénic l'idée c'est de
se soucier cette partie scénique est
important d'essayer de proposer des
spectacles on va voir à l'avenir ce
qu'on va créer en fonction aussi des
retours des contacts qu'on a pu avoir
avec des artistes c'est ça on reste
ouvert à la production de spectacles à
elle sait aussi de promouvoir des
artistes et puis a toujours créé de
nouvelles choses est-ce qu'il faut une
bonne qualité quand même vocale par
exemple pour pour participer aux
ateliers de chant il faut quand même
déjà de bons chanteurs ou
plus le niveau est bon mieux c'est
puisqu'on peut promet après c'est aussi
la mare il ya des marges de progression
donc après les gens investis progresse
très vite et on arrive à des résultats
souvent très bon
l'idée c'est que chacun avance à son
niveau et puis il ya le chant en solo
mais aussi le chant mode chorale ou en
groupe ce qui ressort aussi c'est ce qui
plaît donc chacun trouve ses harmonies
et son niveau et trouve sa place et
c'est un peu dans faut que ça bouge
c'est l'esprit c'est que chacun a sa
spécificité chacun à sa place est ce cet
ensemble fait que faut que ça bouge
existe et une dernière question sur la
jonglerie moi ça m'a toujours épaté les
jongleurs parce que je n'arrive pas mais
beaucoup des débouchés en face à tourner
dans tous les sens sur vous à tomber par
terre c'est quoi les qualités d'un bon
jongleurs
la concentration la concentration la
création l'envi ne pas désespérer
toujours continué à travailler c'est
beaucoup de travail de rigueur beaucoup
de rigueur et puis de la rigueur dans
l'exécution des mouvements et puis de la
folklorique de un peu de choses un petit
peu délurée joyeux dans la création
c'est ça qui fait mais après il ya une
exigence à avoir au départ et puis le
partage
l'esprit jongleurs c'est le respect le
partage est toujours essayer d'avancer
créer de nouvelles choses avec eux rien
passé sur le plateau d' initiative je
rappelle de votre spectacle inspiré sans
ce jeudi 27 juin à 20h30 à la salle
jacques brel à montigny reste encore des
places et les places ne sont pas chères
entre 5 et 3 euros alors ça c'est cadeau
et ben oui ça lui laissera jamais voir
ça vaut le coup d'aller voir
l'association foksabouge